i hear that a lot from racist people and
they'll say
i shouldn't have to feel guilty about
being white right i agree
you're conflating
guilt with empathy that's all it is like
it
saying i see black people struggling
right or i see the plight against a
people of color it's not the same as
saying i'm uh it's wrong for me to be
white in this country nobody's saying
that's a straw man nobody is nobody is
propping that up as an argument at all
they're conflating guilt with empathy
aaron foster on pardon my take earlier
this week i saw a clip also that the pmt
twitter account pushed out there
regarding aaron foster and how
his own experience and the experience of
other african-americans shape how they
view the flag and
when we juxtapose that against you know
the folks who have had a good experience
in this country it's easy to feel
positivity it's easy to feel pride in a
country that has given you so many good
things if you flip it around and you
have spent your life in a country where
you have been mistreated family members
have been mistreated maybe an
acquaintance or a family member has been
killed at the hands of police you feel
differently
and
it is an eye-opener for a lot of us who
hear the words we hear the music and it
stirs a certain type of emotion
for others it stirs a different emotion
big cat and i thought aaron foster was
very eloquent how he explained that
he was and and the part that um put a
lot of it into perspective for a lot of
people i think you know i got the the
most feedback from was aaron foster
talked about you know
white people when they want to figure
out oh my family's from ireland in
england and scotland or russia or
wherever it may be and they trace their
lineage
generation after generation after
generation he he told us he's like i
can't do that
my g my my lineage stops at
a slave plantation and and foster's a
name that was given to my family that's
not my real name so what i can stand on
is different
than what everyone else can stand on and
that history you know that relationship
that he has with america is different
and i think understanding that at a
deeper level because that's really where
the problem is has come out there's
deeper problems but the problem with the
the colin kaepernick protest is people
not understanding
that the flag and the national anthem
don't mean the same thing to everyone
and it's never been about that and it's
never been about that and and what
foster is trying to explain to people is
it kneeling is not about the flag and
even if it were when you say you're
disrespecting the flag and you're
disrespecting the national anthem
there's a different feeling for everyone
in their relationship with this country
because this country has not been
uh right for minorities for a long long
time you know for the history of this
country so it's just
having that perspective understanding it
from a different point of view
i think we need more that people need to
listen more they need to understand more
because it's really easy to stay in your
bubble and it's really easy to just
listen to the people that you know and
listen to people that look like you and
talk like you and it's like hey
maybe sometimes we need to understand
what it's like
to be a minority in this country
and how difficult that is the other one
i had mike was booger mcfarland said on
today's show because we talked about
drew brees he said drew brees went to
sleep on wednesday night and he was
uncomfortable he was uncomfortable
because the world felt like it was
falling on him and he's like you know
what that is
that's like being a black person in
america feeling that uncomfortableness
you know
waking up in the morning and being like
uncomfortable he's like that he lived a
night that of everyone else that he is
basically not understanding so having
those
voices and understanding the the issue
at a deeper level i think is the only
way we're going to move forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports